- Gary, I have a quick question.
My cousin is at the airport,
she needs her identity card.
Could you give me a ride?
- Yes, you can come.
- Thank you so much.
- Let's go. Matt!
- Gary, five words for success?
- Yep, where am I going?
Five words, what?
- Five words for success?
- [Gary] You're gonna die.
I did that one.
Hustle, baby, it's patience.
- Thank you, man.
- When you're young all
of you guys fuck up because
you want it so bad too soon.
I fuckin' worked
20 hours a day until
I was 30 and
didn't talk to anybody.
Waited.
- [Man] Thank you man.
- You guys want it today.
- [Man 2] Yes.
- You got to wait.
How old are you?
- [Man 2] 21.
- [Man 3] 21.
- I'm double your age.
Like you live a whole 'nother
fucking life and you're my age
and you want it tomorrow,
you got to put in real work.
Not gonna come up
with some idea.
Real work.
- [Man 4] Do you think the
knowledge that you get in
university will be
helpful in the real world?
- [Gary] No. But if you
want to get a job, yeah,
but not if you're
building businesses.
- I'll tell my parents and
say, "I fucking quit," bro.
- Alright, ready?
(rap music)